let's let's go into to Mike and Molly
sure
um had you done had you been in any
Pilots had you had what I had yeah
success that you had actor I was very
lucky I I did a lot of uh I got a lot of
parts like I was always uh you know man
number one yeah the plumber or you know
or I got a couple good ones like I was a
detective once and but nothing steady
until um Greg Garcia and Alan
karchenbaum who I just adore uh God Rest
Allen and uh they gave me a reoccurring
part on a show called Yes dear and that
was like a real education to be able to
get an episode every four episodes and
to to learn how that works yeah and then
um and then that kind of prepared me for
Mike and Molly and when I got Mike and
Molly it was
um
it was for me it was terrifying but I
was surrounded by such talent that it
really I mean I really stepped in I
mean in the best way because I had
Melissa McCarthy yeah and the rest of
that cast Lou mustillo Randy Reid Reno
Wilson Nanny Nyambi Swoozie Kurtz Katie
Mixon they were like the Chicago Bulls
yeah because they were you know and they
were all formally trained like Melissa
you know the Groundlings and Illinois
College and Reno went to the school of
Fame the MB Shakespearean train Lou and
Swoozie are off of Broadway yeah Randy's
out of Steppenwolf and then I come out
at a comedy club kitchen you guys want
to do a play and so I learned I got some
extra chicken fingers yeah exactly
everybody's hungry I learned so much
from them and then I had the gift of
having Jimmy Burrows direct us for the
first two years he's the best and then I
have Chuck Laurie overseeing it and yeah
Peter Roth at the time at Warner
Brothers so like I really stepped into
this really you you did find like I mean
there's a lot of you know talking about
a treasure truck there's names you can
name of like boom famous or or just like
successful people like there are names
that you could say well I got in the
show that so and so was running yeah and
that guy's had a bunch of hits and I'd
be like Ugh
yeah but you found no I was surrounded
you're not the best like you said Jamie
Burrows I got to work with him once and
I was like oh yeah I get it he's magic
man and he just knows stuff him and
Chuck share that they just they've seen
so much television that they just know
when shit's gonna work and they tell you
something and you're like that's not
gonna work and then you do it and the
audience lights up and you're like how
did you know yeah like Jimmy would say
something as simple as say the line then
drink the coffee don't drink the coffee
then say the line yeah you do it and the
audience explodes I'm like how did he
know that yeah you know what I mean so I
really absorbed as much as I could from
that I I really tried to learn and and
Melissa was such a great partner because
you know she's so talented and her
improv skills and
um you know um like we got to season
three where you know she'd become a big
tele or big movie star yeah and she you
know we would do two takes for the
writers and then they would let her do
one and then I got to develop this
really cool straight man thing where I
and then I would say to her don't I
don't want to know what you're gonna do
yeah because then the reaction will be
super fun sure and I finally got they
made me that cast especially Lou and
Randy and Reno those three really helped
me so much but I got so comfortable in
that place and again it's about it was
the drama Department again yeah now I'm
with these kids that accept me for who I
am and we all have the common goal of a
great show yeah and I just think that
was a once in a lifetime experience yeah
and I'm very grateful for the show I'm
doing now I'm very proud of the show I'm
doing right now and it's been a lovely
group of people over there but that Mike
and Molly experience was it was it was
really spectacular like I honestly
couldn't believe I was in the middle of
that a lot yeah it took till about
season three where I was really
comfortable not terrified when when
Melissa starts to take off in the way
that she did yeah I mean is there I mean
how is that for you are they hated her
no no but I mean are there moments of
Envy because no no really because what
for not for me and I don't believe for
our cast either we celebrated for her we
rooted her on because I think we were
all at an age that we knew too that her
success was only going to amplify Mike
and Molly it was just going to bring it
was going to bring the tide up for
everybody sure and she was never an
about it you know I mean she
came in the same hair up screaming about
dropping the kids off at school and
you're like you can't not I know so it
was like you know so it was easy to root
for her every radio show I went
on asked me that question yeah but
you're jealous right yeah yeah but see
what they didn't understand was
where I was coming from I I had almost
lost my wife and kid I had almost killed
myself with drugs and alcohol and now
I'm the star of a show
in the middle of this great comedy like
I was just I I used to get excited about
my parking space because I was a fat kid
in Hollywood man I used to have to park
way out you know that strike like gate
there and you got to do the hop by the
time you get there you just look like a
sweaty serial killer and now I'm parking
right by the door are you kidding me and
we have insurance yeah so my perspective
really allowed me to just enjoy that
ride yeah it really did it really did
yeah and it's also honestly I mean this
is a
something and I've talked about before
being I mean being number two I started
to realize oh this is nice it's
wonderful oh this is nice wonderful
she has to deal with so much
yeah she has to talk to so many people
absolutely who whose names I don't
remember yeah
hey Andy and I go hey guy yeah my wife
was always the gift she'd be like that's
so and so yes yes thank you honey hi
Pete how are you you know yeah Burroughs
gave me the greatest advice man uh the
week of the pilot he came up and he said
shut down honey
I got some advice for you I'm not going
to tell you what to do but you need to
hear this I said okay what is it because
I'm going to tell you an old phrase the
fish thinks with the head this is your
number one on a call sheet so you come
in here and act like an
everybody else is going to act like an
so you come in here and act like
a gentleman your set's gonna flourish
it's up to you I hope you make the right
choice and he walked away his greatest
advice anybody ever it's uh yeah I mean
it's and I
I have felt the same thing but I didn't
there I never put it as right he just
nailed it in like four minutes you know
he just knew exactly what I needed to
hear yeah yeah it was really great to me
that way one of the shows I was on there
was an actor who had been on it he had
been acting since he was young and in I
was like one of our first shooting days
and he started to kind of have a little
bit of a fit about
the way his hair was being done or
something like that and I just was
eavesdropping on it and uh one of the
actresses in the show pulled him aside
and she and I heard her say she said
this isn't that kind of show yeah good
she's like she's good for her look
around this is not gonna be like yeah
and to his credit he went oh okay he got
it and then he wasn't you know well I
think it's what you're raised in it's
the culture that you come up in and but
if you if you start with gratitude man
if you if you can hold that gratitude
it's just the great I mean there's 4 000
people outside the gate that want your
job you know don't waste it right you
know and I I told the cast and it was
nice with this new cast you know with
Gina yasharray and falake and and Barry
Shabaka who I love and Matt Jones and
Mary Beth like we have this great crew
again but I said to them when we started
I've been through it and I'm going to
tell you right now it's ending yeah so
how you choose to spend your time on
this journey
is everything yeah it's ending yeah and
in one to five years they're gonna tear
all this down five other squawkers
are coming in here so let's enjoy what
we have yeah let's try to stay there